In the Android Fundamentals course,
you learned all about the Android
manifest.xml file and how this is
used to add permissions to your app.
But before you can access
location on Google Services,
you have to add the ability to use
different location sensitivities.
You can specify that
you want fine location.
Or you can specify that
you want coarse location.
Now what are these?
Fine location updates involve
using the device's GPS,
cell signal, or WiFi to get the most
accurate possible position,
but possibly costing
you extra battery life.
So alternatively,
you can use the coarse location, and
this gets your location using
only the cell signal or WiFi.
It won't be as accurate as fine, but
it'll cost a lot less battery power.